Along with some swag nice
Alright
Hey, everybody. It's Charlie. Hopefully you've had a chance to see black panther this weekend
These are gonna be my Easter eggs obviously a whole bunch of Avengers Marvel Cinematic Universe stuff that they crammed in there
But mostly Easter eggs from the Black Panther comics some really deep cuts for real-life black panther party stuff, too
Be sure to subscribe to get everything if you're just finding me for the first time. There's so much Marvel stuff
That's gonna. Be happening between now and infinity war and there's an Infinity Gauntlet giveaway going on
I'll name a new winner at the end of this -
So just blanket spoiler warning for black panther if you have not seen it yet
Oh wait, just a second ok so here
We go so the movie picks up with a 1990s flashback
And it's a very Black Panther Party Easter Egg the party has its roots in Oakland
But also Ryan Coogler himself is from Oakland
So he wanted to go back there and incorporate some of those ideas like
Militarizing the Black Panther Party in the oppressed peoples around the world and sort of tie that into a more real world message of Black
Panther so here's where we get into some really fun stuff though you go into their apartment
There's an nwa poster on the wall there were a really huge
Hip hop group that embraced a lot of the ideals of the Black Panther Party
the young version of takaka is
Wearing the older Marvel Knights version of the costume with the gold highlights from the Christopher priest run
It was a very urban Black Panther story
It was him in New York City
So it makes sense that you have them in this urban setting that you would do a version of that
But even better the actor
That's playing young - Chaka is the real-life?
Son of the actor that plays the current version of - Chaka the opening credits sequence that explains the origins of vibranium
Actually shows us Captain America's plane
crashing as it flies by during the world war two part of the history scene is really the entire history of the world that they
Show from the dawn of early man - all the stuff that we've seen in the Marvel Cinematic Universe so far in present day
But they also pay tribute
To the very first Black Panther which was actually in a comic book recently where they did the ancient version of The Avengers
Where Odin was sort of the Thor of the team along with the very first version of the Black Panther the whole?
For King takaka to go visit his brother in Oakland was because of that original
Ulysses klaw hi so it explains where he got the vibranium from that he sold to Ultron that they then teased
Would be given back to Black Panther eventually so remember
There's still a lot of a loose sokovia and vibranium in the world
But I think largely they sewed up that
Plotline at the end of the movie when they said the Black Panther would be working with the world to try and exchange
Technology so if it wasn't clear Black Panthers people do try to keep tabs on everyone in the world that has access to vibranium
But really sad to see Ulysses cago, maybe they'll release that mixtape turns out
He really is a musician really minor, Stan Lee cameo not quite as big as we expected
I'll just take that and put it over here not quite as big as the guardians of the galaxy cameo
I'm expecting them to top that for infinity war and Avengers 4. I'm assuming that they filmed all of Stan
Lee's cameos back-to-back, this is because of his advanced stage a lot of times
They'll just have him film a bunch of green-screen scenes and then just insert those into the movies later on
we got a name or reference from the comics for everybody hoping that they use him for the sequel when he takes Klaw in and
Says every breath you take is mercy from me
That's actually directly lifted from a black panther versus Namor moment in the comics
really early on that freaky mask that kilmonger wears is actually made to look like the mask for the character in the comics where's
obviously much more tribal in the comics
They changed his origin story quite a bit originally the name kilmonger was just something that he chose for himself
He did go to school in the United States in the comics
But his father had been
Originally forced to fight for Ulysses Klaw when he was trying to invade Wakanda and steal other vibranium they were fought off Black Panthers father
Exiled all of the people who rebelled against him and that's how kilmongers family wound up in the United States
So he grew up there in vowed revenge for the disgrace to his family
Philia was totally okay that the movie changed that to turn him into more of a hamlet Lion King type character the speaking of character
Changes obviously in Baku just completely omitted the man ape origin of the character in the comics
The only small references that they make to that are calling him the great gorilla
He wears an 8
Mask made to look just like the one that he wears in the comics when he's fighting black pants
Earlier in the film in the interest to his palaces carved to look like that of an ape so that's about as close as they
Get to that for obvious reasons
Pretty sure everybody picked up on that back to the future reference when she gives him the sneakers just like Michael J Fox his sneakers
From Back to the Future 2 apparently black panthers father was a huge fan of those movies
also
Pretty sure everybody
Detected that the broken white boy the Sheree was talking about was Winter Soldier a great another broken white boy for me to fix
I'm hoping that vision is another broken white boy in the next movie
I made a reference about that during my Avengers video, and I'm not sure people understood what I was talking about
But I've already done a couple videos explaining. How she fixed his mind, but effectively he is back to normal
She'll give him a vibranium arm in there calling him the white wolf. Which is probably one of the bigger Easter eggs
Hopefully Sebastian Stan signs a new Marvel contract, and they can use them in future Marvel sequels
But he does seem like he's down to do that so maybe White Wolf in black panther 2
The movie changed a little bit about black panthers powers the heart-shaped herb, and the Dajjal eeeh the way the movie depicted it
It's really of your own creation
it's sort of this psychic area that you just travel into and it's just made to look like the place that you're thinking about the
Most so that's why kilmonger goes back to the place where his father died in why black panther meets his father?
Amidst all these acacia trees
And if it wasn't clear those other Panthers in the tree are the spirits of previous versions of black panther so in the comics
He's the king of the dead he can speak to the previous versions of black panther and get advice from them
This is the movies way of invoking that the first time that he talks to his father
They stay
Panthers when he goes back to the second time to talk to his father and ask him why he left kilmonger behind as a
Child you see them all in human form the reason why they're all male is because they're all the previous Black Panthers
This is how I think it's possible they can bring kilmonger back in the second film because they're pretty clear that he wanted to
Die at the end of the last film so unless Black Panther defied his wishes and threw him into cold storage to heal him
He's going to be dead, but here's the thing because he had taken in the heart-shaped herb and communed with the Panther goddess
So it's possible that Black Panther could go to the spirit plane and speak to kilmonger spirit
And that's how you bring Michael B. Jordan back because he was a fantastic character
Maybe they'll find a way to incorporate him maybe in a flashback
There's just a number of ways they could accomplish that
They were a couple more iconic comic book panels when kilmonger tosses Black Panther over the falls
That's right out of the comics also when Black Panther is charging on the Rhinos
I know everybody wants to see those come back during infinity war
Isn't like I said the Marvel Knights version of the costume in that 90s flashback
they also kind of did the same thing with the more modern version of the costume the kilmonger war towards the end of the
Film big Disneyland big Coachella shout out at the end of the film
There's only
Theories at this point that Black Panther is the person who bought stark tower because that was being sold at the end of spider-man
Homecoming new tenant moving in but remember
timeline explainer black panther takes place about a week after Captain America Civil War the events of spider-man
Homecoming take place several months after that so if you don't know when Civil War happened that was during the summer because it was his
Summer retreat with the Avengers and that homecoming dance is usually something that happens around
October for most people in the United States so the end of Black Panther takes place a couple months before the end of spider-man
Homecoming so don't worry
We'll do more timeline explainers as we get closer to
Infinity war because the movies don't take place one right after the other in the timeline anymore
The other real big comic book Easter Egg is when they talk about how they lied and say Ulysses Klaw stole all their vibranium you
Told us that it was all gone, and you didn't have any more dr.
Doom Ulysses Klaw and Thanos himself all on separate occasions tried to take all of wakanda's vibranium
There was a time in the comics when Black Panther was forced to render all
Vibranium in the world inert on a more permanent basis and for those of you asking there actually is
Vibranium in the Savage Land, but remember we don't have the x-men characters yet
So as of right now in the MCU the only place you can get it is inside the borders of Wakanda well
Let me know in the comments if you spotted any other Easter eggs that I didn't mention in the video
What'll happen is is I'll be doing more Avengers more black panther related stuff in the next couple of weeks
Obviously as we head towards infinity war in
Deadpool - there's gonna be so much stuff dropping so there any special videos that you want me to do
Just let me know in the comments
Congratulations to the latest giveaway winner jmv. Please private message me so I can get your contact details
There was a new round on this video
I'll just name a winner when I
Post-new Marvel click here to learn about all the infinity gems after black panther and click here for my black panther post-credits scene video
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight